the amount of child sexual abuse images
and videos online is vast and expanding
rapidly in 2022 we received over 32
million reports to the Cyber tip line
just last year for 2023 that number
increased to over 36 million this is a
global problem it is international in
scope and because of the instantaneous
nature of many of these internet-based
platforms that users use to traffic in
this type of material it is circulated
across the globe
24x7 some social media companies such as
meta the parent company of Facebook and
Instagram receive high marks from Child
Protection advocates for screening out
sexual abuse material others including
Elon musk's ex formerly known as Twitter
have gutted content moderation teams
those people were fired or they left the
company
leaving X wide open for the circulation
of this kind of material while producing
or possessing child pornography is a
serious federal crime social media
companies face few consequences when it
appears on their platforms online sex
Predators know that the internet is
really an an open ground where they can
find children who um want to communicate
who want to connect analysts say social
media companies use freedom of speech
art arguments to evade responsibility
for more effective moderation of harmful
content online and to maximize profits
there really is in in my estimation a
fairly significant cynicism here by the
firms where they constantly appeal to
wanting to protect ostensibly their
users's first amendment rights when
really what they're protecting is their
own right to make decisions pro and con
about content
that suits them best financially while
Congress has proved ineffective at
regulating social media some local
governments are taking the lead last
month New Mexico sued meta for failing
to prevent harm to children and last
week New York city mayor Eric Adams
officially designated social media as a
health hazard protecting Children online
an enormous problem with no effective
solution Rob Reynolds Al
Los
Angeles make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer